Steve I want to talk about the source
material for this film it's something
that you saw when you were growing up
could you tell us what you remember from
the original widows why it stuck with
you and why it was something you wanted
to revisit they're just women that sort
of had a purpose really often we see a
TV show you know it's the hero or the
heroes sort of you know bump into things
whatever these women had to there was a
necessity and an app so a Leticia and
being 13 years old seen these women on
TVs on TV I had an immediate connection
with them you know they were being
judged by their parents they're being
judged of not being capable similar how
was being judged a 13 year old child
growing up in London and you know often
I will project myself onto Sean Connery
on James Bond or Toni Weissmuller you
know paint azam but I miss seeing it and
recognizing and seeing myself in these
women
Gillian when you think about the things
that you want to retain from the
original story and the things that you
want to change what were the most
important elements to preserve and where
did you figure that you needed to make
the most dramatic changes from the
source material yeah I mean Linda
LaPlante had given us some beautiful DNA
to begin with with the miniseries and so
we knew you know we'd loved the idea of
the widows and the heist but certainly
you know one of the huge things was and
making it current and making it feel
real was that idea that we wanted these
women to be incredibly identifiable in
present day that we wanted them you know
therefore women we want some of them to
have kids for instance we wanted to see
what child care looked like in the
middle of this incredibly dangerous
heist we wanted it to be very clear you
know that the the danger and the and the
fear and and what it looked like when
when four women were coming together to
make a team and we also want to make
sure that they were of different races
and economic backgrounds so that when
you looked on-screen you know for a
blessed change that they
like women of today Steve at what point
did you decide that you wanted to locate
this story in Chicago and why was that
city important in terms of what it told
about the broader story that you were
trying to illustrate well began to show
for 22 years first thing I was invited
to do an exhibition in Museum or not
there's my first solo show and at the
same time my girlfriend at the time who
now is my wife was going to Democratic
convention when think Bill Clinton was a
present so I say my first footprint in
Chicago was art and politics and since
going there back and forth I just it was
about you know these sort of racial
divide
you know Lithuanians Lithuanian polish
Irish African American Latino it was
people rubbing shoulder to shoulder with
each other it's such a small you know
proximity for a drug or a Philly where
it everywhere everything is and of
course it was just one of those places
what it was for me as well as all of
that was I want to place it in the
heightened contemporary Western City and
for me Chicago had all the things they
want to deal with politics corruption
policing religion you know etc etc in we
know what the typical studio
remake of widows is it's called widowers
and it's about men that the tables are
turning leonie's alright Kahlua Brian
Terry said exactly so how do you make
sure given what this story's about that
you preserve the idea that Steve and
Gillian are after that this is not
widowers this is widows and to make sure
that you are creating a team around
Steve that's gonna be able to help him
realize his vision I mean yeah yeah I
mean it sort of started off when we
first when Fox inner agency got ahold of
the rights and when we started
developing it basically people would go
that's a that's a unique idea that's a
novel idea and and the show is 83 so
it's it's been a long time between that
novel idea and this novel idea and
hopefully that changes but I think you
know what makes it sing is the
incredible actors that we had in in the
for leads and those four women and their
incredible performances but I think also
what's really important is that great
actors also played the male supporting
roles
in films like this you know that it's
it's about the caliber not assuming to
drop because it's a female lead but
being celebrated because it's a female
lead and I think we had that with great
performances from our leads and great
you know male supporting forces from our
male actors Elizabeth before I asked
about how you came into the project I
want to ask you and Biola was there a
day a moment when you were on set that's
the four leads of this film and said to
each other either out loud or to
yourselves holy shet here we are four
women leading a studio film yes I think
almost every day to be asked that I was
saying to Steve not long ago I'm so glad
that I was aware of how special this
experience was making this film because
I so actively soaked up every second of
this set from being under Steve's
guidance and having that incredible
collaboration with his brilliant mind
and heart and soul and then working with
these women who I just adore and you
know we were we were so lucky to that
Steve set up space for us before we even
got on set that we were really bonded
and we understood that we could be very
honest with each other and I think that
sort of that meant that the work we were
doing was was honest and sort of
revelation you know I learned a huge
amount doing it and also we just we were
reveled in the fact that we could play
real women right you know you don't
often get that you you saw you sort of
start with yourself and then it's like
those paper dolls you used to have and
you were a kid you start your like
putting different things on you to
filter yourself down to meat basically
you basically to become an extension of
male fantasy or female fantasy but the
fact that Steve wanted you know for lack
of a better term real women you know to
headline you know this movie I thought
was very novel and I think viola and
Elizabeth is very important the high
is not something that's going to make
them rich it's going to allow them to
survive that these women have no
alternative it is this or their lives
essentially cease that the stakes are
not about having money
the stakes are about surviving and that
seem to be very important I think in the
adaptation can you talk a little bit
about how that was how you talked about
that with Steve and Gillian and why
that's the important driving force for
these characters behavior that was my
first thing because I've seen a lot of
movie with people rob banks and they're
coming from seemingly normal lives why
do people rob banks I mean listen I have
been through periods in my life where
it's been hardcore but I've never you
know except when I was nine I tried to
steal a brownie but um tried you didn't
get no I was thrown out of the store but
um but yeah I think I think it's
important to see that because sometimes
it's about a Sophie's Choice that's when
people do things completely outside of
the box but it also became a metaphor
for these women taking ownership of
their lives and that's what I love so
much about this narrative that it's not
just this thinly veiled story of these
women just like sort of saying you know
my husbands are dead now we need some
money we need some cash to pay the rent
stories have a deeper nucleus that start
at the core of politics of economic
subterfuge of sexism of racism and um I
think Steve was like you know what I'm
gonna tackle this giant and I'm really
good at tell the story from its core so
it made sense to me that that they
committed this heist it just made sense
he made sense of it Steve thank you so
much Gillian Ian Elizabeth and Biola
and thank you all for coming out